joining us with a deeper look at all
this is Sahil Kapur national political
reporter for Bloomberg News good morning
Sahil good morning
okay let's first start with the item of
legislation that's taken up a lot of
discussion this week the Senate tax bill
tax reform in general is it Senate gonna
pass this there's a decent chance it
passes out of the Senate
there's desperation here among
Republicans like I've never seen in
Congress to get this done they have not
repealed the Affordable Care Act they
have not built a wall they have not done
an infrastructure package they could end
this year go home for Christmas with no
accomplishments and they really want to
avoid that you think don't do it before
the end of the year they are so eager to
do it before the end of the year because
they want to complete the year with some
accomplishment it's possible it has to
pass the Senate and then the house has
to take that up as is or they go but
they go to conference and sort out the
differences what are the impediments at
this point to it I would say three big
impediments number one is the mixing of
health care politics with taxes they
tried to smash the ACA earlier this year
it did not work out
they have awakened a sleeping giant to
the progressive base in the healthcare
industry with doctors hospitals and
insurers now saying that repealing the
mandate is going to drive up premiums
and cost people their coverage the
second is the issue of the deficit
there's about a trillion and a half in
red ink in this bill and there still are
some Republican deficit hawks who are
concerned about that the third is an
issue that Senator Ron Johnson of
Wisconsin has raised he's the one
Republican who is so far come out
definitively against this package as it
is he worries that it benefits large
corporations too much at the expense of
smaller businesses like the one he used
to run well and senator Susan Collins
who's a Republican said she's worried
about the bill because whatever attack
savings middle-income families may see
they may be wiped out because insurance
premiums will rise Senator Collins and
Senator Murkowski cast two pivotal votes
to prevent repeal of the Affordable Care
Act earlier this year they have both
sounded concerns about that Collins told
me plainly it is a mistake to mix these
two issues a third Senator John McCain
who also voted against Obamacare repeal
earlier this year seems a little more
open-minded to the repeal of the mandate
so we'll see let's turn to Alabama
special Senate election which is coming
up quickly here in early December we
heard from from the story a short time
ago that clearly there are elements of
the Republican Party in Alabama who are
do not want things to change there back
in ROI more what is the Republican
leadership in Washington saying to each
other right now well this is a
devastating no-win situation for
Republicans they either win that seat
and invite in an alleged child molester
into their ranks or they lose that seat
which should be a slam dunk seat in a
ruby red state that Republicans won by
literally 97 percent in 2014 so they're
considering all options to try to to try
to save that they've talked about a
potential write-in candidate
the current incumbent who was appointed
after sessions became the Attorney
General has suggested he's not
interested in that there has been some
chatter about potentially delaying the
election imagine the precedent that
would set if you're doing that for
political purposes it doesn't look
likely that's going to happen the
governor has ruled that out so it looks
like they're stuck right now well but if
worry Moore ends up winning this
election
what can Mitch McConnell do can he
prevent him from entering the Senate the
law says that they cannot prevent him
from entering the Senate but the Senate
can expel him now the last time this
happened was after the Civil War and you
know it's a it's been a long time in a
long time and it would be an
extraordinary thing to do and there
would be obviously blowback from frankly
the Trump base which is still on the
side of Roy Moore the the nativist wing
of the party which continues to support
him so it's a it's a tricky proposition
there's no easy situation here and by
the way if they lose this seat
they're already slim margin in the
Senate of two votes is cut in half
yeah imperil imperils everything else
that they're trying to do meanwhile
Democratic Democrats have their own
dilemma here with the sexual harassment
allegations against Al Franken he's
owned up to these there's gonna be an
ethics hearing is how damaging is this
to Franken and wood and what are the
Democrats to do about this it's very
damaging and his initial response was
was a little casual and and and you know
dismissive about this but he eventually
put out a statement apologizing and
taking responsibility promising to
cooperate with the ethics investigation
in the Senate we are at a real
inflection point I think in this country
when it comes to issues of sexual
harassment and assault we have seen a
men at the highest levels of news and
entertainment and politics accused of
sexual misconduct going back decades and
decades and I think whether it was the
election of President Trump who had his
own accusers coming forward or something
else that precipitated it
there are just a lot of women coming
forward and saying enough is enough to
see change it's not Hilda Kapur thanks
very much for being with us this morning
thank you